wir hatten jetzt in den letzten beiden
vorträgen wie gesagt zu kann zu viel
gehört kann selbst und die nach cannes
tische rezeption neu kann tennis muss in
russland wir werden im folgenden vortrag
dem abschließenden vortrag etwas zu
hegel hören und meinem vortrag kommt
jetzt die aufgabe zu diese lücke nur
etwas zu schließen vollständig kann
diese zeitliche lücken überhaupt nicht
im rahmen eines solchen vertrags
geschlossen werden aber ich möchte mich
eben mit schelling und schopenhauer
befassen und ihre rolle in russland und
ich glaube dass die sehr sehr zentral
ist weil sie gerade eine alternative zur
art der rezeption von kant und von hegel
gibt und der grund wird darin bestehen
dass beide schelling und schoben aber
nicht so sehr den begriff der vernunft
oder dient des geistes regel ins zentrum
ihres denkens stellen sondern vielmehr
den begriff der natur und vor allem den
des willens und anhand dieser anderen
begriffs konstellation zeigt sich auch
eine ganz andere rezeption russland wie
mir scheint
es kann ja wie gesagt nicht um
vollständigkeit gehen sondern ich möchte
nur schlaglichter auf diese rezeption
dann in russland werfen und dabei möchte
ich folgendermaßen vorgehen ich möchte
also zuerst schelling und schopenhauer
in der rezeption betrachten wie hat
schopenhauer schelling rezipiert das ist
sehr interessante hat ich nehme schon
mal vorweg er hat seine untersuchung
über das wesen der menschlichen freiheit
sehr genau studiert und man kann das
daran zeigen dass er in seinem
persönlichen exemplar viele
unterstreichungen vorgenommen hat und
randnotizen angebracht hat das nur ganz
kurz fertig geht darauf noch genauer ein
schelling wiederum hat sich von kant
durchaus auch abgegrenzt es geht also um
das verhältnis von schelling und
schopenhauer im verhältnis zu kant und
dann im verhältnis zur russischen
rezeption und nicht zuletzt auch um das
verhältnis zu regeln und hegels
rezeption russland also es geht jetzt um
eine sehr komplexe konstellation von
begriffen von rezeptionen in meinem
vortrag
er hat zwei teile im ersten teil möchte
ich wie gesagt schopenhauers schelling
rezession behandeln und dabei vor allem
auf die begriffe des willens und der
natur fokussieren wie sie sich von den
begriffen bekannt von kants willens
begriff unterscheiden
in einem zweiten teil werde ich
analysieren wie die jeweilige willens
und natur metaphysik im russischen
denken fruchtbare anknüpfungspunkte
darstellen konnte und wie sich diese
rezeption an einigen ausgewählten
beispielen näher demonstrieren lässt
hier ist dann auch der schritt zu
nietzsche nicht weit der bekannt show
bekanntlich schopenhauer sehr geschätzt
hat zu dem wir eigentlich heute einen
vortrag von frau bosiljka hätten hören
sollen aber
die aus persönlichen umständen
eigentlich kommen konnte die aber ihren
nietzsche beitrag für den anschluss
geplanten sammelband uns fest zugesagt
hat
soviel zur einleitung erster teil
schelling und schopenhauer das
verhältnis von schelling und
schopenhauer ist aus systematischer
perspektive besonders hinsichtlich des
begriffs des willens brisant und
ergiebig als zentrale anknüpfungspunkt
erweist sich dabei für schopenhauer
schellings 1809 erschienene
untersuchungen über das wesen der
menschlichen freiheit und die damit
zusammenhängenden gegenstände die
sogenannte freiheit schrift wie sie kurz
genannt wird
darin spielt wie schon sagte der begriff
des willens eine ganz zentrale rolle wie
rezipiert jetzt schopenhauer diese
freiheit schrift schopenhauer hat wie
ich schon vorhin sagte in diesem
exemplar dieser schrift sehr
interessante handschriftliche notizen
gemacht und auch unterstreichungen
angebracht sein eine edition dieses hand
exemplars wird im nächsten jahr erstmals
der forschung vollständig zugänglich
gemacht es zeigt schopenhauer als einen
kritischen leser der aus seiner über
jahre hindurch geführten
auseinandersetzung mit der
idealistischen natur und freiheits
philosophie schellings die maßgeblichen
impulse für seine insgesamt wohl wird
mächtigste die wohl wild mächtigste
willens metaphysik des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts erhalten hat dieser band
wird von der freiburger philosoph in
lohr erhöhen und damit arbeit von
sebastian schwarz für demnächst nächsten
jahr in der reihe schelling jana des
frommen holzburg verlags erscheinen
was interessiert nun schopenhauer
besonders anfällig
es ist vor allem die willens
metaphysische deutung der natur und des
seins zitat wollen ist uhr sein zitat
ende schreibt kelly an einer prominenten
stelle
eine freiheit schrift und er fährt fort
sie tat es gibt in der letzten und
höchsten instanz gar kein anderes sein
als wollen
von hier aus ist es nicht mehr weit zur
schopenhauers welt als wille und
vorstellung profil gewinnt dieser
willens begriff bei schelling und
natürlich auch bei schopenhauer in
kritischer abgrenzung natürlich auch
anknüpfung an cantz nach kans
grundlegung zur metaphysik der sitten
ist der wille zitat nichts anderes als
praktische vernunft
er ist noch mal ein zitat ein vermögen
nur dasjenige zu wählen was die vernunft
unabhängig von der neigung als praktisch
notwendig dass dienst als gut erkennen
gemäss kants kritik der praktischen
vernunft als der wille der eine will
sofern er der reine verstand der eine
solche zahlen vernunft heißt durch die
bloße vorstellung eines gesetzes
praktisch ist also erkannt eine sehr
enge verzahnung von vernunft und wille
die dann so bei schelling ich sage jetzt
nicht ganz aufgelöst wird aber durchaus
in ein kritisches verhältnis gebracht
wird interessant sind nun wie ich schon
sagte
schopenhauers randnotizen schellings
freiheits schrift an einer zentralen
stelle der freiheits schrift die
folgendermaßen lautet ich zitiere jetzt
aus schellings freiheits schrift zitat
das prinzip sofern es aus dem grunde
stammt und dunkel ist ist der alten
wille der kreatur der aber sofern er
noch nicht zur vollkommenen einheit mit
dem licht als prinzip des verstandes
erhoben ist es nicht fasst bloße sucht
oder begierde das heißt blinder wille
ist diese passage in der freiheits
schrift notiert schopenhauer kurz am
rand die tat vor spuk von mir also hier
ist im grunde genommen schon mehr von
mir alles gesagt hier komme ich
irgendwie schon vor
auch schellings rede vom willen als uhr
sein hat schopenhauer in seinem
handwechsel blatt deutlich unterstrichen
diese ähnlichkeiten mit schelling
sollten schopenhauer später übrigens den
vorwurf des plagiats einbringen was er
damit zu entkräften er damit zu
entkräften versuchte dass er auf den
gemeinsamen ausgangspunkt kant verwies
also schelling und schopenhauer zu
schopenhauer er selbst habe eigentlich
nur die särge quelle wie sharing kann
nämlich und dann eigenständig ihn weiter
gedacht schopenhauers willens mit erfolg
geführt dann aber zu einer von kants
theorie ganz und gar entgegensetzten
während verkannt das erhabene moralische
gefühlte achtung welches vernunft
gewirkt von ihm genannt wird und zitat
die einzig echte moralische triebfeder
ist ist dies nach schopenhauer gerade
das intensive und emotions gedrängte
gefühl des mitleids dieses gefühl der
achtung jedes mitleid ist nicht wie bei
kant intentional nur auf prinzipielle
reine vernunft subjekte gerichtet
sondern vielmehr auf alles willens und
lebensfähige in dieser ethischen
abweichung von kant bei schopenhauer die
durch die fokussierung auf einen willens
begriff stattfindet der nicht mehr aufs
engste an die vernunft gebunden ist
manifestiert sich mit blick auf die
spätere russische rezeption ein
entscheidender anknüpfungspunkt es geht
darum wie die mögliche existenz des
menschen zu angemessen zu denken ist der
zugleich in einen lebendigen kontext der
natur eingebunden ist und nicht von der
natur streng unterschieden gedacht
werden muss wie es in kants kritik der
fall ist
schopenhauer wirft denn auch keins
moralphilosophie zitat einen gänzlichen
mangel an realität und dadurch an
mögliche wirksamkeit vor er fährt fort
wir müssen umso mehr bedauern das reine
abstrakte begriffe apriori ohne realen
gehalt und alle irgendwie empirische
grundlage wenigstens menschen die in
bewegung setzen können von anderen
vernünftigen wesen kann ich nicht
mitreden
als man sieht schon deutlich so eine art
von brutto existenz philosophie
aufscheinen auch wenig schopenhauer
jetzt nicht als existenzgründer suchen
zeichnen möchte
schopenhauer geht es also darum eine
materielle grundlage einer moral und
motivation theorie zu finden welche vor
allem praktisch wirksam werden kann und
der existenz des wirklichen menschen
entspricht dagegen wirft erkannt vor
sich auf einem zitat bequemen
ruhepolster dem kategorischen imperativ
der rein praktischen vernunft
niederzulassen ohne praktisch relevant
werden zu können
die von schopenhauer verwendet der
metaphorik zur bezeichnung des
kategorischen imperativs sei es als
ruhekissen spinnen gewebe oder pure
schale ohne kern und noch schlimmer ab
rio riss tisches seifenblase impliziert
im wesentlichen zwei kritikpunkte zum
einen das wählen eines echten tragenden
fundament zum anderen aber der vorwurf
einer moralisch praktische impotenz es
muss deswegen zu schopenhauer zunächst
daran gegangen werden zitat der moral
das breite ruhepolster wegzuziehen
ich will jetzt nicht weiter auf
schopenhauers kritik der kantischen
moralphilosophie eingehen das ist auch
größtenteils bekannt mir ging es jetzt
hier nur darum zu zeigen dass wohl eher
wie kant auch den willens begriff ins
zentrum stellt er diesen doch diesen
doch eine ganz andere wendung
indem er ihn in diesem gefüge der
philosophischen begriffe eine ganz
andere rolle
mit blick auf den begriff der vernunft
zu weisen ich werde deswegen jetzt nicht
weiter auf diese kritik eingehen man
könnte jetzt noch vielsagend zu chopins
analyse der kantischen vernünftig
nachdem ich nun schellings und vor allem
schopenhauers verhältnis zu kant und zur
sich gegenseitig behandelt habe will ich
jetzt im folgenden mich der russischen
rezeption dieser komplexen relation und
begrifflichkeit zu finden
ich komme zum ersten punkt schellings
aufnahme im islam sieg von biel fällt
die tübinger geisteswissenschaftlerin
und slawistin hat in ihrer umfassenden
habilitationsschrift aus dem jahr 2000
die im jahr 2008 erschien ist zu den
anfängen der russischen schelling
rezeption
treffend hat diese schrift treffend mit
selbst oder natur betitelt und ist dabei
vor allem auf die frühe rezeption durch
den russischen arzt daniel bilanz kiel
eingegangen der selbst bei schellings
studierte um die medizin seinerzeit auf
ein natur philosophisches fundament zu
stellen wie thomas barth in seinem 2005
erschienenen buch mit dem titel
schelling in russland gezeigt hat blieb
diese diskussion der naturphilosophie im
ausgang vorstellung nicht auf
deutschland oder den deutschsprachigen
raum beschränkt bad weist darauf hin
dass die bedeutung schillings wird die
russische philosophie nicht hoch genug
eingeschätzt werden kann
vladimir petrovic oder jet ski
bezeichnete seinerzeit schelling mit
niemand verglich seinerzeit schelling
mit niemand geringerem als dem entdecker
schlechthin
mit columbus ich zitiere das ist auch
der erste teil meines titels die tat
oder die ski zu beginn des 19
jahrhunderts war schelling das was
christoph kolumbus im 15 jahrhundert war
er entdeckte den menschen einen
unbekannten teil seiner welt von dem es
nur farbe längliche überlieferungen gab
seine seele wie kolumbus fand er nicht
das was er gesucht hatte wie kolumbus
weckte er unerfüllbare hoffnungen
doch wie kolumbus gab er der tätigkeit
des menschen eine neue richtung
alle stürzten sich auf dieses wunderbare
blühende land manche vom beispiel des
kühnen seefahrers angeregt manche um der
wissenschaft wenn manche aus neugier
manche aus gewinnsucht die einen
brachten von dort viele schätze mit die
anderen nur affen und papageien aber
vieles ging auch unter soviel zur
einschätzung später sollte weniger liga
und seinem schelling buch von 1982
darauf hinweisen dass wielands die zu
tag die gute botschaft über den neuen
stern der philosophischen horizont zu
strahlen begann das ist also schelling
und die klassischen deutschen
philosophie in das russische reich
gebracht haben zitat ende
als entdecker der seele so dieses
vorherige zitat musste schelling auch
aus ästhetischer und literarischer
perspektive in russland von interesse
sein
andré belly der russische dichter und
theoretiker des symbolismus schrieb im
jahr 1923 über schellings
naturphilosophie ich zitiere sinn und
natur sind eins der grund der natur ist
die natur der idee und die philosophie
der identität schellings vergewissert
sich in einer berglandschaft lauscht dem
singen des sturzbach beschreibt exakt
was aus dem singen des bachs in deiner
seele wird wieder begriff der seele die
wahrheit von goethes gedanken offenbart
sich in aller deutlichkeit die
manifestation geheime zeichen der
naturkraft des vermögens das leben des
bewusstseins zu begreifen
die metamorphosen der ideen gleichen mit
der metamorphose der pflanzen organismen
die metamorphose der idee ist konkret
exakt wahrnehmbar beschreibbar und die
beschreibung der exakten fantasie des
sands ist auch philosophie also man
sieht her es geht durchaus darum dass
die philosophie schellings identitäts
philosophie die die natur stark
aufwertet ein ausgangspunkt für
literarische zugänge ist in der die
seele deren entdecker schilling nach der
russischen rezeption ist weiter
analysiert werden kann und auch die
vernunft ja auch die fantastische wieder
viel mehr bedeutung bekommt ich komme
jetzt zum zweiten teil der rezeption
schopenhauers aufnahme in russland
wie steht es also um den einfluss
schopenhauers in russland der bamberger
slayer ist peter tilgen hat darauf
hingewiesen dass zitat die russische
wirkung schopenhauers bis heute in
vieler hinsicht eine terra incognita ist
in senigallia schopenhauer biografie
liest man im kapitel schopenhauer und
die russische kultur zitat der einfluss
schopenhauers in russland zeigte sich
schneller klarer und umfassender als zum
beispiel in frankreich oder in england
und zucker in deutschland selber also
hat schopenhauer schon als ein sehr
zentraler denker dargestellt und peter
tilgen begründet das folgendermaßen der
russische schopenhauer siegen kennt mit
drei problemen klar wissen oder die
problematik dieser rezeption besteht
darin islamisten zu tilgen sind keine
philosophen und philosophen keine
slawisten zahlreiche wirkungen shoppen
haus in russland sind nicht oder nur
ansatzweise untersucht und das
zusammentragen der zusammentragen der
verstreut erschienen sekundärliteratur
deren jeweils russisch und deutsch das
nicht fremdsprachige titel nicht allen
zugänglich sind ist eine schwierige
aufgabe
wie steht es nun um die russischen
schopenhauer rezeptionen konkreten
zunächst scheint prima fazit jedenfalls
dostojewski ein potenzieller
schopenhauer rezipieren zu sein wenn man
darauf reagiert darauf fokussiert dass
der wille durch in seinem werk eine
große rolle spielt nun hat aber reinhard
laut bereits in seinem durchzug fc buch
von 1950 darauf hingewiesen das zitat
dostojewski schopenhauers philosophie
gekannt hat aber dass sie nicht auf ihn
gewirkt haben zitat er entwickelte seine
anschauung von villen in kontroverse zu
den positivistischen und elitär ist
ischen lehrern seinerzeit das hatten wir
auch ein vortrag von der musik gehört
wie der utilitarismus eine rolle spielte
und laut begründet es damit sagt
zurawski hebt den willen nicht zu einem
metaphysischen grundprinzip wie es
schopenhauer getan
also wenn auch bei dostojewski die
schuppen habe rezeption ziemlich unklar
ist es gibt meines wissens keinen
direkten nachweis auf die neuesten
forschungen sagen
soweit ich informiert bin dass es keinen
direkten einfluss in seinem werk gibt so
ist es aber doch bei tolstoi ganz anders
also tollste bei tolstoi lässt sich das
wirklich im detail zeigen er hat
schopenhauer sehr geschätzt und aktiv
rezipiert ende august 1869 schreibt in
einem brief an den damals bedeutendsten
russischen lyriker fantasie fed zitat
wissen sie was der diesjährige sommer
für mich bedeutet hat ununterbrochene
begeisterung für schopenhauer und eine
reihe geistige genüsse die ich niemals
zuvor erfahren habe ich habe alle seine
werke bestellt und gelesen und lese sie
immer noch auch kant habe ich gelesen
und wahrscheinlich hat kein einziger
student in seinem kurs so viel gelernt
und so viel begriffen wie ich in diesem
sommer ich weiß nicht ob ich meine
meinung einmal ändern werde jetzt
jedenfalls bin ich überzeugt das shoppen
haben
der genialste aller menschen ist das ist
die ganze welt in einer unwahrscheinlich
klaren und schön abbildung
ich habe begonnen ihn zu übersetzen
wollen auch sie sich an eine übersetzung
machen wir könnten zusammen herausgeben
wenn ich in leese ist nur unbegreiflich
wie sein name unbekannt bleiben konnte
es gibt höchstens eine erklärung eben
jene die er selbst zu oft wiederholt
nämlich dass es auf der welt fast nur
idioten gibt und tolstoi als frau sofja
tolstaja schrieb im februar 1870 in der
tagebuch zitat den ganzen letzten sommer
hat er tollste gelesen und sich mit
philosophie befasst von schopenhauer war
begeistert kegel hielt er für lehre
phrasendrescherei
tatsächlich und da hat glaube ich seine
frau recht gehabt ist in russland
schopenhauers denken wesentlich
sympathischer aufgenommen worden und
wesentlich einleuchtender angesehen
worden als es im falle von hegel war wir
werden jetzt in folge vorteil bestimmt
noch interessantes dazu hören aber peter
tilgen hat mit blick auf die russische
schopenhauer begeisterung von einer
zitat russischen trägt disposition
gegenüber schuppen aber gesprochen
rezeption so ticken pflegen um so
intensiver zu sein
die stärker zur antizipation ausgeprägt
war
zwei aspekte seien dabei hervorzuheben
die persönlichen lebensumstände autoren
und die allgemeinen zeitumstände
russlands ich denke man kann wirklich
hier schopenhauer ein kontrast zu
bringen während schopenhauers willens
mit der physik durchaus intuitiven
anklang gefunden hatte weil vielleicht
schon antizipation in russland vorhanden
waren und er irgend ein vorbereitetes
feld eintrat diese rezession
so wurde doch hegels philosophie diese
absolute vernunft optimismus nicht immer
ganz verstanden und bedeutet wurde
nachher aufgenommen oder als
selbstverständlich aufgenommen so
wiesmann stadtmauer der fall war und ein
gutes beispiel ist hier der berühmte
harmonie satz aus hebels vorrede zu den
grundlegenden dingen der philosophie des
rechts was vernünftig ist das ist
wirklich und was wirklich ist das ist
vernünftig dieser satz stieß in russland
zunehmend auf ablehnung und wurde durch
schopenhauers ansicht geschichte zwei
ein wirrwarr sinnloser impulse abgelehnt
abgelöst iwan turgenjew hat in seinen
erinnerungen erinnerungen festgehalten
und das finde ich ziemlich
aufschlussreich was das verhältnis von
der russischen schopenhauer zu
russischen hedl rezeption anbelangt
zitat viele probleme machte damals in
moskau der bekannte ausspruch hegels was
vernünftig ist es dass es wirklich was
wirklich ist das ist von
mit der ersten hälfte des spruchs was
vernünftig ist das ist wirklich waren
alle einverstanden
doch wie sollte man die zweite was
wirklich ist das ist vernünftig
verstehen musste man wirklich alles als
vernünftig anerkennen was damals in
russland existierte interpretierte und
diskutierte und entschied die zweite
hälfte des ausspruch ist nicht zu
akzeptieren
peter schiergen wiederum sieht den grund
verschoben habe das freundliche aufnahme
in russland in einer gewissen ja geistes
gemeinsam gar nichts das haltung der tat
noch mal tilgen
schopenhauer konnte nicht zuletzt
deshalb in russland zu einflussreich
werden weil sein pessimismus nicht eine
totale abkehr von metaphysischen decken
sondern eine kombination von metaphysik
und materialismus an boden also nicht
dieses extrem von jäger diese totale im
metaphysik und auch nicht dieses extrem
des utilitarismus damit er sich ja auch
durch die jetzige auseinandergesetzt hat
zu einer gewissermaßen eine synthese aus
diesen beiden anteilen das hat ja auch
schon der person schopenhauer sehr
deutlich der ja in danzig geboren ist
und in danzig waren die einflüsse sowohl
der angelsächsischen philosophie eben
als auch die der kontinentalen bisher
drei der berühmtesten roman
schriftsteller und realisten russlands
zugänge tollster und lescott der
bedeutendste damalige lyrik aphasie fed
sowie eine der führenden kritiker
nikolaustag auf bildeten dann das
literarische empfangskomitee für den
einzug schuppen haus in russland wird
denn als multiplikatoren und etablierten
einen russischen schopenhauer realismus
vor allem in der schönen literatur
damit bin ich auch am ende meines
vortrags zusammenfassend lässt sich
sagen dass vor allem schopenhauer in
dieser lücke sage ich jetzt mal zwischen
kant und hegel ein ganz bedeutendes
stellung einnimmt weil er wie mir
scheint durchaus an bereits bestehende
russische
tendenzen in der geistesgeschichte
anknüpft und weil er eben durch seine
philosophie es schafft verschiedene
tendenzen starken materialistische
tendenzen aber durchaus auch
metaphysische tendenzen diese willens
musik in eine systematische einheit zu
bringen die also das beste aus beiden
welten zusammen bringt die durchaus auch
die realität die existenz ernst nimmt
und nicht wie bei hegel idealistisch
vielleicht etwas verklärt könnte man
sagen
und also hier schalten wir wirklich
einen grund für die besonders zentrale
stellung schuppen haus in der russischen
geistesgeschichte zu liegen vielen dank
für die aufmerksamkeit